gardez la franche au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trophée des valises à paris
lorsqu'il lui arrive à la bbc
la statistique dont tout le monde parle
en ce moment l'inflation n'en finit plus
de grimper plus 5,2 pour cent le mois
dernier par rapport à mai 2021 un
chiffre qui interroge et pèse une
nouvelle fois sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français avant bas ont payé une
entrecôte dans l'est avant de partir en
brocart grise 900 l'avaient quelque
chose enfin à peu près maintenant faut
mettre 2000 2002 alors il ya une
augmentation
voilà il ya une augmentation un bonjour
françois de closets journaliste
essayiste alors ce micro trottoir à 50
ans pourtant il n'a pas pris une ride il
aurait pu être tourné ce matin toujours
la même rengaine on n'a pas trouvé de
remède sur cette inflation est ce qu'il
ya un remède non l'inflation ça vient à
certains moments on n'arrive pas à la
freiner et c'était le cas dans les
années 70 et puis ensuite dans les
années 80 et 90
pc considérablement et on était arrivé à
cette situation il ya quelques années
qu'on faisait une économie d'inflation 0
ne savait plus vers l'inflation
gouvernement pour ça on pouvait pas le
faire on était à 0-0 et puis c'est
reparti il faut considérer que
l'inflation c'est un peu les courants et
les vents sur l'océan on s'est très mal
prévoir l'organisent ce face à cette
situation économique actuelle
aujourd'hui prouvent il ya un
responsable et baby boomers cette
génération née dans les années 45 60 que
vous accusé d'avoir laissé la france en
ruine retraite d'être travail vous venez
d'ailleurs le publier la parenthèse
boomer c'est aux éditions fayard grâce
aux archives de l'ina ben on va tenter
de comprendre comment on en est arrivé
là l'inattendu s'intéresse à votre
pouvoir d'achat cette semaine
[Musique]
bonjour camille d'auxerre alors dans les
années 40 les français avaient une idée
très concrète de ce qu'était l'inflation
oui c'est peu de le dire puisque le taux
d'inflation était à près de 60% on
sortait de la seconde guerre mondiale
les outils de travail étaient détruits
il y avait des pénuries les prix
flambent et est l'une des solutions
trouvées par le gouvernement à l'époque
c'était le contrôle des prix mais un
contrôle au forceps et autoritaire menée
par l'état
pour digne à la hausse non tu n'y as
1947 c'est l'après guerre mais la france
souffre toujours les prix flambent les
français ne peuvent plus manger et
manifestent contre la vie chère
d'autant qu'il est déclenché il faut
substituer à la psychose martel de la
haute une sorte d'émulation pour la
baisse et tous les secteurs de
l'économie française suivront le mot
d'ordre perte de 5% le filtre infernal
wattel privé contre le cycle infernal de
l'inflation la baisse des prix imposés
par le gouvernement de léon blum porte
ses fruits certains commerçants
convaincu de l'efficacité du geste ont
même été plus loin c'est à 10% en
certains endroits que la baisse a été
portée cette politique autoritaire du
contrôle des prix et mener son relâche
pas question que les commerçants
profitent de cette vague inflationniste
pour s'en mettre plein les poches le
gouvernement a lancé l'offensive
d éthique les commerçants de détail de
l'alimentation du mandataire des halles
aux marchands de poissons doivent
afficher côte-à-côte prix d'achat et
prix de vente indiquant ainsi la marge
de leurs bénéfices après les étiquettes
prix d'achat prix de vente un nouveau
magasin est né le magasin témoins ici
les prix servent de référence aux
clients la création des magasins témoins
ont provoqué une baisse sensible sur la
charcuterie et par incidence sur la
viande en général sur certains marchés
les consommateurs transformer en
contrôleur bénévoles aux lèvres pour les
afficher les prix les plus bas et la
grèce du bon marchand réflexe aimait
bien les autres commerçants se met au
diapason pour les prépas baril côté des
commerçants dénoncent éveil côté des
prix imposés par l'état un état qui va
même jusqu'à vendre directement de
l'avion de français pour s'assurer du
juste prix le gouvernement a pris
l'initiative d'ouvrir sur les trottoirs
des inventaires volant pour mettre en
vente la viande achetée pays hyper l'an
passé soit l'expérience de début dit oh
la france yves du gouvernement contre
les profiteurs et pour le bifteck moins
cher est commencée et la police du
bifteck mon cher n'hésite pas à
intervenir chez les détaillants les
doubles messieurs de la police
économique repose avec gentillesse et
sous peine de saisie une rectification
des étiquettes au prix du barème conseil
suivi généralement de très bonnes
volontés le boucher n'est pas sans
entrailles et on commence à entrevoir
que l'énergie peut peut-être avoir
jean meng
et ce sera le cas l'inflation va
diminuer françois de closets aujourd'hui
on parle d'une inflation à 5 % et on
panique qu'est ce que ça voulait dire
une inflation à 60% elle était à 60 % au
lendemain de la guerre et ç'a permis
entre autres au gouvernement de payer
ses dettes sur le dos des gens qui
évidemment vous à partir de répondre
pour rien mais il y a eu effectivement
une économie française en 1945 qui était
sorti de la guerre dans un état exemple
pas l'occupation et allemandes les nazis
l'avaient épuisé et il ya eu beaucoup de
travail les français se sont remis au
travail vraiment et ils ont redresser la
france et donc l'inflation à ce stade là
est quelque chose de panique en
d'affolant 1 il faut bien faire
attention que à la fois un peu
d'inflation est nécessaire c'est un
stimulant une économie sans inflation et
une économie sans jeunesse et une
économie de vieux jeux le savoir mais en
revanche que l'inflation dépasse 5 10 15
20 % à ce moment là c'est tous les
mécanismes économiques qui se détraque
il n'y a pas de solution simple sans
parler de solution il ya des contre
mesures possibles et notamment une
option augmenter les salaires est ce que
c'est une bonne idée 5e pas bonne ou
mauvaise idée en tout cas il s'agit de
revenir finalement à ce qu'on a connu en
france jusqu'aux années 80 indexer les
salaires sur les prix pour maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat des français la dernière
grande indexation elles datent des
années 70 l'inflation est forte les prix
augmentent mais les salaires aussi
les prix m'ont fait constater par
exemple sur les
mois de juillet au mois de septembre il
y avait 6 centimes sur 1,9 j'ai trouvé
que c'était beaucoup au début des années
70 l'inflation repart à la hausse les
oeufs le pont tout augmente alors pour
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
français le gouvernement un recours à
l'indexation des salaires pour préserver
le niveau de vie des français est une
condition que les salaires augmentent au
moins autant que les prix et pour que ce
niveau de vie soit améliorée il faut
évidemment que la hausse des salaires
dépassent celles des prix le niveau de
vie est maintenu mais l'inflation aussi
c'est la spirale inflationniste
l'augmentation des prix fait augmenter
les salaires et vice versa on ne s'en
sort pas alors en 1982 la gauche est au
pouvoir et l'inflation et à plus de 12%
le gouvernement décide un plan de
rigueur il faut une mesure brutale le
blocage des prix et de tous les revenus
une mesure brutale bloquer les prix et
les salaires c'était il ya quarante ans
cette décision est-ce que vous souvenez
françois de closets de la réaction des
français
les français l'ont très mal pris
d'autant que c'était après ce printemps
extraordinaire de 91 avec l'argent par
tourner augmenté partout les budgets
salaire tout augmenter et puis en 83 on
s'aperçoit qu'une chose que c'est pas
une solution est en fait il faut
retrouver de l'équilibré de la santé
économique c'est ce qui a été fait en 83
par
jacques delors quand ils ont fait une
politique de rigueur qui est la seule
politique économique qu'a eue la france
en 50 ans françois de closets vous
restez avec nous camille d'auxerre merci
beaucoup pour ses explications on va
continuer à parler économie et inflation
comment les journalistes les médias ont
vulgarisé ces sujets parfois un petit
peu difficile d'accès pour le grand
public mais d'abord le zapping de
l'inattendu
[Musique]
robert kennedy est mort
robert kennedy était une affirmation du
pays une affirmation de l'honnêteté
intrinsèque du pays de son désir de paix
de son désir de voir les conditions de
vie s'améliorer pour tous il semble bien
que les israéliens aient décidé de
neutraliser toutes les bases
palestiniennes de la région pour le
moment nous en sommes encore un raid de
représailles si la syrie participe
directement au combat comme cela semble
être le cas il faudra alors parler d'une
véritable guerre un point noir qui se
déplace lentement sur un disque d'or
voilà le spectacle rarissime que
l'univers offre depuis hier soir aux
habitants de la terre
la place de la concorde multicolores du
jaune du bleu de l'oranje autour de
l'obélisque et coiffé pour la
circonstance d'un ballon de football
l'europe l'asie l'afrique l'amérique
réunis pour jean pascal et vitruve un
créateur du spectacle voilà les valeurs
universelles de ce sport fraternité
esprit l'équipe tolérance égalité
cadeau du jour une rame de tgv modèles
réduits signée christian lacroix est
l'élu ce renouveau du train et symbolise
cette ville nouvelle merci d'accepter
tout rappelle retrouve aujourd'hui ses
visiteurs du dimanche elle va revoir les
cousins de province les collégiens en
vacances les militaires en promenade et
se fera c'est pernel il se renouvelle à
chaque saison bonsoir votre soirée
[Musique]
voilà l'inattendu s'intéresse à
l'économie cette semaine avec françois
de closets notre invité et géraldine
corner lavaud qui nous a rejoint bonjour
gérad il tient jusqu'au viens de parler
hausse des prix est ce que vous
comprenez quelque chose à la définition
de l'inflation l'inflation est un
déséquilibre économique résultant de
l'inadéquation entre les offres
spontanées les demandes formulées au
prix courant du début de la période
d'analysé reste a expliqué le
déséquilibre les mêmes études
économiques distingue des explications
néo keynésienne néo classique ou
monétaristes et structuraliste vous avez
compris en fait pour comprendre la
relation on peut procéder bien autrement
voilà vous avez compris françois de
creuser on est d'accord c'est
incompréhensible
alors pendant des années vous avez
procédé autrement en vulgarisant
l'économie à la télévision que
pensez-vous de la couverture
journalistique de la situation et qu
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut expliquer aux
gens et que l'inflation bien sûr existe
un et vous à l'augmentation des prix ne
rêve pas mais que la mesure que l'on en
donne et burins d'arbitraire 1 pour
prendre un exemple l'essence augmente si
vous prenez tout dans votre voiture à
bon voudrait pouvoir d'achat diminue si
vous n'avez pas de voiture vous en
fichez donc il n'y est l'église une
mesure de l'inflation soit n'existe pas
alors en tout cas nous on s'est mis
d'accord sur un chiffre officiel celui
là + 5 2 % pour la france le mois
dernier par rapport à 2021 alors il faut
l'expliquer simplement au grand public
et ça c'est un vrai casse tête pour les
rédactions jarvis et c'est très
compliqué d'expliquer ce concept
d'inflation on a des chiffres on voit
des images comme ça deux paniers qui se
vide qui se remplissent des étiquettes
qui augmente mais il ya eu des
journalistes qui ont été vraiment plus
imaginatifs et qui ont pris leurs
crayons de couleurs en 1973 l'inflation
à cette époque là est à 9 3% et elle a
les traits d'un monstre
l'inflation est d'abord apparu comme un
monstre surgit spontanément des sociétés
modernes
on l'a vu passer comme une tornade
c'était l'inflation galopante
puis on a compris que même invisible
elle était la menaçante prête à profiter
des difficultés des nations c'était
l'inflation l'attend
aujourd'hui on s'est habitué à sa
présence on l'a admise pourvu qu'elle ne
soit pas trop voyantes c'est l'inflation
rampante
l'inflation cas ce que c'est une hausse
des prix oui plutôt non disons que plus
l'inflation rapide plus les prix montent
vite mais plus les prix montent vite
plus l'inflation et rapide
est ce que c'est bien résumé parce que
c'est le rôle aussi de la télé de faire
ces petits courts-métrages pour
comprendre des concepts économiques dans
l'enjeu quand on favorisait beaucoup
les cibles ouais j'avais des indicateurs
on revoyait périodiquement les gens et
on déplace et vous vous ou votre outil
c'était le fameux diagramme c'était bien
sûr et mon dieu
coupez mais
oui c'est vous c'est nous at il dit le
panier ça c'est un diagramme qui
permettait de comprendre vraiment les
rouages de l'économie et les
conséquences de l'invasion très et mois
après mois on suivait ça bougeait ici ça
bouge est là et vous et comprendre aux
gens pourquoi il faut que la croissance
augmente pour que le chômage diminue
pourquoi lorsqu'on écoute et si vous
voulez vous savez que c'est vous
explications d'époque quelque sorte le
tableau de bord de l'économie française
de toute économie capitaliste d'ailleurs
quatre secteurs la demande l'activité
l'inflation le chômage des zones claires
et ici ça va bien et puis des zones
sombres ici pas de commande hi-fi la
récession ici l'hyperinflation ici un
million et demi de chômeurs la règle du
jeu consiste évidemment à placer toutes
les flèches dans les parties claires
vous voyez aussitôt que ce n'est pas
possible si on n'a pas de chômage c'est
que l'économie s'emballer alors on
risque d'hyperinflation quand est ce que
vous avez l'idée de fabriquer ce
diagramme mais vous savez à l'époque on
pouvait pas aujourd'hui on traduit rsa
en termes aider l'équipe avec ça
ressemble un petit peu les fortunes mais
c'est
simplement ce que oui je voulais c'est
la différence là qu'entre eux
l'inflation le monstre c'est non je
voulais que les gens comprennent et
visualise ce que tu es la relation entre
ces différentes grandeurs
parce que c'est ce qui est à la base de
je dirais la physiologie économie et sa
cette séquence était donc pendant le
journal télévisé mais en 1978 vous en
avait déjà un petit peu parlé mais vous
allez carrément animer une émission
économique qui s'appelait l'enjeu
premier magazine économique à la
télévision c'était une volonté et de
raymond barre ministre de l'économie et
premier ministre jusqu'à mars 1978 quels
ont été les coulisses de la création de
cette émission
y'a pas une coulisse ou me jean louis
guillaume a dit françois faut que tu
fasses une émission un magazine
économique
non mais que oui mais c'était
typiquement alors je veux dire ce que
pierre sabbagh appelé de pmd pin merde
voilà ça nous est imposée qu'est ce que
tu veux faut le faire bon c'est faire
imposer par raymond kalla oui et donc on
n'y croyait pas sa défaire une émission
qui embêterait tout le monde qu on
supprimerait vite enfin bon fallait le
faire enfin démontrer que alors j'ai
pris mes deux acolytes alain weber
emmanuel de la taille et on a essayé de
faire une véritable émission une
émission où on entrerait des choses il y
aura de l'émotion il y aurait du
spectacle et ou en même temps on aurait
pas honte d'expliquer parce que les gens
sont demandeurs les explications il faut
cesser de dire waouh faut surtout pas là
en faut avoir le courage de dire
maintenant on va vous expliquer
justement lors du premier numéro tout de
suite vous nous disiez l'enjeu de cette
émission je fais jose le jeu de mots et
son concept bonsoir l'économie voyez
vous on ne parle guère quand elle va
bien en ce moment on est bien obligé
d'en parler d'en parler beaucoup parce
que c'est vrai il ya des problèmes et à
travers ces batailles économiques
c'est notre vie notre argent nos emplois
nos salaires qui sont en jeu et c'est de
cet enjeu nous vous parlerons chaque
mois ou plus exactement que nous vous
montrerons manuel de la taille à la
recherche en équipe et moi mais alors
tout de suite nous allons voir en
fonction de l'actualité
ce qu'il y a dans ce premier numéro nous
allons vous présenter cette émission a
duré dix ans il y avait donc une
appétence de la part des français des
téléspectateurs pour l'économie pourtant
on dit souvent que les français n'aiment
pas l'économique ça les intéresse pas
mais studio et on dit de la même façon
que va pas parler d'économie parce que
ou si tu auras vous faites de la
politique vous soutenez tel parti tel
autre et tout ça était bio donc on peu
s'intéressent ça provoque pas des
problèmes politiques particuliers ce que
je regrette après il ya eu capitale mais
qui est en fait sur le secteur privé le
la télévision publique n'a plus fait ce
genre d'émission je crois que j'allais
vous dire 88 donc fin de l'enjeu après
géraldine on les cherche un les
émissions qui parlent d'économie à la
secte il reste pas grand chose alors
vous l'avais dit il ya un capital qui
est sur m6 mais sinon on est sur des
émissions de consommation et non pas
d'économie donc comment gérer son argent
comment économiser ou sinon il ya des
chaînes très spécialisés qui s'adresse
la cades est initié est vraiment moi
personnellement je ne comprends pas
grand chose on est bien loin de vos
diagramme qui parlait à tous est ce que
c'est dommage anges du qui est plus ce
genre d'émission sur le service public
mais c'est scandaleux est aberrant enfin
que
unifiant le sar est bon
pour faire de bons spécialistes tout à
l'heure on a aperçu jean paul chapelle
françois lenglet maîtrise du problème
donc on pouvait on peut faire de telles
émissions simplement il faut qu'à voir à
la tête de la télévision des gens qui y
croient qu'ils croient à la volonté
des téléspectateurs de s'enrichir de
comprendre des choses c'est faux que la
science où l'économie vont pénaliser
l'audience vous souligner l'absence de
spécialistes en 2008 les journalistes
échos sont un petit peu dépourvu face à
la crise des subprimes effectivement
parce que deux formations les
journalistes sont souvent plus
littéraires sont pas très copain avec
les chiffres 1 je plaide coupable alors
en 2008 quand il ya eu la crise
financière et bah c'était la panique et
dans certaines rédactions comment
expliquer cette crise financière comment
expliquer les subprimes sans émissions
et qu il va l'expliquer toute cette
crise au sein des jt dans des sujets
d'une minute trente
avant il fallait presque pleuré pour
vendre des sujets économiques dans les
journaux parce que c'était où elle aime
c'est trop compliqué ton truc ça va pas
intéresser les gens brutalement ça a été
un séisme ça a été un une révolution je
dirais dans le journalisme économique à
la télévision peut-être en particulier
on a fait des sujets sur les cette prime
on a expliqué ce qu'était des créances
la titrisation on a même utilisé des
mots comme ça qui sont des individus des
mots du vocabulaire financier qu'on
n'avait jamais utilisé est à la télé
donc ans à nous mêmes on a appris on
apprenait en marchant il y avait des
jours on se disait mon dieu j'ai jamais
arrivé a déjà à ce que moi j'en
comprends je vais jamais arriver à le
rendre cohérent et finalement on y est
arrivé je pense que dans toutes les
rédactions c'est la même chose on
s'interdit moins de traiter des sujets
difficiles aujourd'hui
mais vous rendez compte cette crise de
2008 on pouvait la faire vivre en allant
aux états unis en voyant tous ces
malheureux qui on avait fait acheter une
maison qui pouvaient pas se payer et qui
était tout heureux et puis un jour
europe et pouvaient impayés et tous
dehors c'était quelque chose très
concret c'est simplement ça pouvait pas
se faire en une minute ou journal
télévisé qu'est ce que vous voulez dans
la presse écrite on trouve normal qu'il
y ait les quotidiens et qu'il irait
hebdomadaire que de me guider revue et
qu'il n'y ait des livres bon c'est tout
à fait normal à la télévision on
pourrait faire la même chose au lieu de
quoi la télévision fait maintenant la
radio filmée c'est à dire pour traiter
tous ces sujets sains on a des
spécialistes on a eu quatre trois
médecins un présentateur pendant la
crise sanitaire là on a des financiers
quand il ya la crise économique
maintenant il ya des généraux qui
viennent pour la crise en ukraine la
guerre en ukraine non il ya un angle
avait toutes les qualités mais parce que
les télévisions ne croit plus ne croient
plus que l'économie que la science
puisse
donner matière à des émissions des
émissions qui évidemment serait
largement regardez c'est imbécile de
dire le bébé qu'il est en bas si on
n'est pas en bas on trouvera pas non le
public il peut aussi monter et il est
tout heureux d'avoir mon là on a souvent
pointé du doigt le manque d'appétence
des français pour l'économie mais aussi
la leur formation les français sont sont
pas bons en économie oui et en 1967 un
numéro entier de l'émission aujourd'hui
madame qui était consacrée à l'économie
comment parler de l'économie afin de
rendre sa audible de tous en plateau
deux journalistes échos et voici ce
qu'ils en pensaient que vous voulez dire
que le journaliste nous sommes quelques
autres est très médiocre par rapport à
tout ce qu'il faudrait expliquer je
crois que là vous prêcher un convaincu
et si vous les cherchez déjà versé en
accusation mais c'est bien ce à dire une
chose c'est que nous si on analyser les
messages tels qu'ils passaient pas c'est
que les gens comprennent vraiment de ce
que nous avons voulu écrire en toute
bonne foi je suis sûr qu effectivement
ça ça imposerait beaucoup d'humilité il
faut du manque de préparation de vos
concitoyens je reviens à l'explication
précédentes on ne voulait pas que
français soit informé donc la première
tâche c'était de ne pas leur enseigner
l'économie à l'école alors que dans le
monde anglo saxon n'a pas décomplexion
conflit eh bien on enseigner est ce que
vous pensez comme ce journaliste que les
français ne savent pas assez ne sont pas
assez formés sur les problèmes
économiques à l'école si vous vais leur
parler si vraiment vous beaucoup de
travail pour arriver à avoir quelque
chose de simple
quelque chose de représentable et qui
donne le sentiment là j'ai compris voilà
c'est ça qui vous réussir c'est
énormément de travail mais si vous le
faites vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir un
public qui lui connaît par coeur
l'économie
parler d'économie à des économistes
c'est faire quelque chose très chiant
françois de closets alors aujourd'hui
vous n'avez plus d'émissions mais vous
avez toujours un avis très tranché sur
l'économie et vous venez de publier ce
livre donc la parenthèse boomers aux
éditions fayard ou vous apporter des
solutions pour gérer notamment le
vieillissement de la population un livre
qui est incontournable pour expliquer
pour bien comprendre l'économie merci à
vous de votre présence et de votre
éclairage dans l'inattendu merci à vous
géraldine pour ce dossier on termine
avec la traditionnelle pépites et cette
solution proposée par raymond alors
séparé montbard désolé nous c'est
raymond devos pour lutter contre
l'inflation c'est peut-être un petit peu
moins technique mais écoutez c'est pas
mal du tout
[Musique]
je pourrais dire simplement parce que
j'ai entendu des choses et gère légère
et en même temps préoccupante comme le
prix de l'essence va augmenter mais moi
il ya quelques années gk reprendre
certains textes il ya quelques années je
disais c'est ça les gens se plaignent de
l'essence va augmenter les sens aux
commandes de sa jeudi mais les gens
n'ont qu'à faire comme moi ils n'ont
qu'à prendre pour 100 francs moi j'en
prends pour un enfant et j'ai toujours
payé le même prix alors le jour du oui
mais pour ce prix vous aller de moins en
moins loin je réponds je vais vous
voilà je vais où je veux nous aussi on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine sur le
canal 27 et bien entendu toute la
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit ce li na ou ceux de france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes et les honneurs prévost
corlieu viviane barney merci à elle
merci à vous d'être avec nous chaque
semaine et merci à toute l'équipe qui a
préparé cette inattendue à bientôt
[Musique]